[Music]
if we want to improve the health
situation of the European societies and
if we want to tackle the probably the
most important challenge which is
obesity of the European population we
have to work together
the tactical came right on time it was a
need to highlight this issue in a very
high political level why we need to have
fighting against air pollution because
it's about health why we need to help
clean water because it's about health we
need to change fundamentally paradigm
and fundamentally encourage all
governments national parliaments NGOs
and business operators to understand
every house is it issue of economy
finding the way to make the population
healthy needs
inter-sectoral collaboration and this
needs stepping aside and also see the
the needs of another sector and taking
them into account to be open the novelty
is that we are doing now not separately
but together with other policies for the
commissioners center but also research
environment and climate to contribute
really to fulfill our commitment on
sustaining development goals
I think it's reinforcing sanction the
spirit of belonging we have an identical
aim and we work together so we can
overcome all the barriers and all these
artificial bureaucratic differences and
problems and probably that's the most
important we can regain our energies and
we can continue our job
[Music]